>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Searching
the BARD Collection.
>> Judy: Hello, I'm Judy Dixon,
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover searching
the BARD collection for titles.
To search the collection, from
the BARD Express Main Menu select
search BARD.
You will be presented with a
keyword search term edit box.
You can enter a keyword or you can
tab over to the Search by Type drop
down box and change the
search type to search
by DB number, author, or title.
You can also narrow your results by
using the Subject Filter to exclude
or include various subjects.
By default, all subjects
are included.
Enter a key word in the box.
For this example I am going
to use the word Winter.
Press enter to initiate the search.
>> NVDA: Winter.
Loaded search BARD
winter items 1 to 50.
Search BARD.
Search BARD, press F1 for help list.
A prairie boy's winter.
Author Kurelek, William, 1 of 50.
>> Judy: The available books
containing this word will be
presented in a list view.
The focus will be on the
first book in the list.
Use the arrow up and down keys
to browse the search results.
From this screen you can add
titles to your wish list,
download them, or access
their details.
Additionally, you may change
the sort order of the book list.
If you are going to download
or add to your wish list more
than one title from the list, I
recommend you use the advanced view.
Switch to the advanced view using
the keyboard shortcut control L.
For more information on
transferring and downloading books
and managing your wish list see
the other tutorials in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.